die Kämpfe rund um die Stadt bachmuth im
Osten der Ukraine gehen unerbittlich
weiter und sie fordern tagtäglich neue
Opfer auch unter Zivilisten hier in der
nahegelegenen Stadt Kostja kamen gestern
durch Artilleriebeschuss mindestens
sechs Menschen ums Leben
unterdessen will die ukrainische
Regierung an ihrem Ziel festhalten auch
die schwarzmeerhalbinsel Grimm zurück
zur erobern russland hatte sie 2014
annektiert in einem 12-punkte planen das
Nationalen Sicherheitsrats der Ukraine
heißt das unter anderem man wolle die
krimbrücke abreißen so wie Beamte die
mit den russischen Besatzern
kollaborieren strafrechtlich verfolgen
einen schnellen Waffenstillstand und
friedensundierungen mit Russland fordern
dagegen viele ehemalige SPD-Politiker
und Gewerkschaftsbosse in Deutschland zu
den Unterzeichnern gehören
ex-spd-chef Norbert Walter borjans
Wolfgang Thierse Klaus Uwe beneter
Günther Verheugen und frühere
Bundesminister wie härter däublerin und
Hans Eichel
scharfe Kritik an diesem Aufruf kommt
vom ukrainischen Botschafter in Berlin
das ist purer Zynismus gegenüber den
zahlreichen Opfern der russischen
Aggression so olexes
[Musik]
uns ist jetzt der stellvertretende
Vorsitzende der der Unionsfraktion im
Bundestag zugeschaltet Johann
wade-stellvertretendes Mitglied im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss und im
Verteidigungsausschuss schönen guten
Morgen guten Morgen Frau von Waldenfels
lassen Sie uns zunächst über den
sogenannten friedensabell von
SPD-Politikern und Gewerkschaftern vom
Wochenende reden SPD-Fraktionschef Mütze
nicht hat den Brief gelobt und gesagt er
komme zur rechten Zeit finden sie das
auch
nein das finde ich nicht und ich komme
in die etwas eigenartige Situation als
Oppositionspolitiker den Bundeskanzler
verteidigen zu müssen aber das will ich
gerne tun die Bundesregierung verfolgt
gemeinsam mit allen westlichen Partnern
einfach an die Vereinigten Staaten eine
klare Strategie wir Deutschland
unterstützt die Ukraine die überfallen
worden ist die angegriffen wird jeden
Tag wir haben gerade wieder die
schrecklichen Bilder aus bachmut glaube
ich gesehen und insofern ist es wohl
File jetzt zu fordern es müsste endlich
Waffenstillstand eintreten dafür ist
jeder jeder ist für
Friedensverhandlungen aber da wird man
erst hinkommen wenn die russische
Aggression gestoppt wird wenn Russland
aufhört Krieg zu führen übrigens ja mit
Söldner Truppen also
wir haben erleben hier eine Rückkehr ins
Mittelalter und was wir jetzt brauchen
ist Einwirken auf Russland da kann nicht
nur sagen dafür könnte man sich jetzt
engagieren der um keine können wird
derzeit leider nur mit Waffenlieferungen
helfen das heißt der badepool es gibt ja
trotzdem eine durchaus berechtigte Frage
welche alternativen ist zu einem
endloskrieg schon gibt oder heißt es man
bleibt jetzt bei der Strategie mit
Unterstützung der Ukraine also mit
Waffenlieferungen Putin an den
Verhandlungstisch zwingen zu wollen und
wenn ja muss man dann nicht einfach noch
mehr Waffen liefern und vor allem
schneller
na man hätte in der Vergangenheit
schneller liefern müssen also den
Vorwurf machen wir ja der
Bundesregierung schon länger es hat sehr
lange gedauert bis wir schützen Panzer
und Panzer geliefert haben jetzt sind
sie endlich da jetzt sind auch Soldaten
erste Soldaten ausgebildet das hätte man
früher machen können aber es wird jetzt
mit Konsequenz gemacht
Deutschland Hilft mit einem sehr großen
Beitrag die Bundeswehr leistet hier an
der Ausbildungstätigkeit hervorragendes
es ist leider in der jetzigen Situation
das muss man ganz nüchtern so
feststellen so dass wir derzeit nicht
viel mehr machen können als der Ukraine
bei ihrem Freiheitskampf zu helfen und
jeder Waffen Stillstand jetzt würde ja
bedeuten dass die russische dass die
russische Aggression Erfolg hatte dass
ein Teil der Ukraine besetzt ist und das
in diesen besetzten Gebieten wieder das
wahrscheinlich passiert was wir in
Botschaft schon an schrecklichen
Kriegsverbrechen gesehen haben also
jeder der jetzt sagt wir dann mal da
stehen bleiben wo wir jetzt sind
müsste das mal der Ukraine erklären und
müsste sich mal vorstellen aber das auch
vorschlägt denn das für Deutschland so
gelte Herr wadepool angesichts dieser
neuen Sicherheitslage wollte die Ampel
ja eigentlich eine nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie längst vorgelegt
haben das verzögert sich aber offenbar
haben Sie dafür Verständnis nein
überhaupt nicht die Ampel scheitert an
ihren eigenen Vorstellungen und Plänen
sie bekommt ja auch in diesen Tagen es
nicht hin ein Eckwerte für ein Haushalt
zusammen zu bekommen die Ampel ist aus
meiner Sicht stehen k.oh wann bräuchte
man eine nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
mehr als jetzt oder das ist doch
vollkommen klar deutschland muss sich
neu organisieren wir müssen uns auf eine
Situation einstellen wo wir kriegen in
Europa haben und das können wir nicht
mit den Mitteln der letzten 30 40 Jahre
machen wir haben erlebt das kritische
Infrastruktur
angegriffen worden ist die Pipelines in
der Ostsee wir erleben Cyberangriffe
jeden Tag wir wissen die Bundeswehr muss
sich neu aufstellen also deutschland
muss sich rüsten um sicherheitspolitisch
gut aufgestellt zu sein die Ampel ist
dazu offensichtlich nicht in der Lage
nicht nur Deutschland beschäftigt das
sondern natürlich auch
Europa auch die Nato und diese Woche
treffen sich die NATO-Außenminister und
Ministerin da geht es ja eben auch nicht
zuletzt um die Ukraine was versprechen
Sie sich von diesem Treffen
na ich glaube die NATO erlebt
glücklicherweise einen neuen Aufschwung
wir erleben das Finnland der NATO jetzt
beitreten kann meine feste Erwartung ist
dass es auch für Schweden möglich ist
ich appelliere dringend an unseren
EU-Partner Ungarn den Weg dafür frei zu
machen und ebenso dringend an die
Nato-Partner Türkei den Weg dafür frei
zu machen weil die NATO einfach ein
Bündnis ist was defensiv ausgerichtet
ist was aber Sicherheit verspricht wir
müssen uns bedauerlicherweise darauf
einstellen dass wir für die
vorauszusehende Zeit Sicherheit in
Europa nur gegen Russland werden
erreichen können und nicht mit Russland
wir arbeiten dafür dass wir auch mit
Russland wieder in einer
Völkergemeinschaft zusammenarbeiten
können wo man sich auf gegenseitige
Abmachung und Verträge verlassen kann
aber zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt können wir
unsere Sicherheit nur gewährleisten wenn
wir unsere Bundeswehr und die NATO gut
ausrüsten dazu sind wir zum Glück auf
einem sehr guten Weg sagt der
stellvertretende Vorsitzende der
Unionsfraktion Johann badepol bedanke
mich für das Gespräch sehr gerne